MALE SPEAKER: Hey, everyone.
My name is [INAUDIBLE].
I'm from the privacy team
here at Google.
Thank you for coming to this
Authors At Google talk.
Let me tell you a little bit
about our guest today.
He was born and raised just down
the road in Palo Alto.
Tad Williams has held more
jobs than any sane person
would care to admit to.
He's done singing in a band,
selling shoes, managing a
financial institution, throwing
newspapers, and
designing military manuals,
just to name a few.
As a writer, he has been one of
fantasy's most beloved and
brightest stars over 30 years,
and has written such
bestsellers as "Memory, Sorrow,
and Thorn" series, the
"Otherland" series, and the
"Shadowmarch" series.
He's here today to talk to us
about "Happy Hour in Hell,"
the latest book in his
critically acclaimed "Bobby
Dollar" series.
Please welcome Tad Williams.
TAD WILLIAMS: Thank you.
What I'm actually here today to
talk to you guys about is
pretty much anything we
want to talk about.
I have some slightly formal type
things I could do, like
actually do a reading, but I'm
also perfectly happy just to
answer questions.
I can ask questions, actually.
I can do that, too.
So I'm fairly casual
any which way.
Do you guys want to hear some
reading, or you want me just
to talk about stuff?
I mean, I'm very informal
with these things.
Some of you seem to be familiar
with my work already.
The gentleman here has already
made a sarcastic remark about
my inability to make deadlines,
so he clearly knows
something about me.
So I'm just curious if anybody
has any preferences in terms
of what they want.
I'm putting you on the
spot early, OK?
So I'm going to expect
feedback here.
Anybody want a reading?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
TAD WILLIAMS: Yeah?
OK.
I'll read a little section from
the first "Bobby Dollar"
book, because then I don't
have to explain all the
different things.
Well, I still have to explain,
but I don't have
to explain as much.
The most important thing to
realize about these books--
the main character--
oh, that's my badge.
That is not on the cover of
every book, I promise you.
The main character in these
books is an angel.
He's an Earthbound angel.
He works for the heavenly
bureaucracy, and his job is
more or less to act as an
advocate or a public defender
for the souls of the
recently dead.
And in the course of doing
this, normally, he has a
fairly normal sort
of on Earth life.
He has an Earth body, he has
Earth friends, but he mostly
hangs out with other angels
who are doing the
same kind of thing.
The book also takes place,
just in case there's
references to it, in the
peninsula area, but it is an
imaginary version where, for
my own sake-- because I was
writing a kind of a noir
crime-ish thing, I needed an
urban area.
I needed a city to be a good
setting for anything that has
kind of a noir tint to it.
And because of that, I invented
a city, because I
grew up in the suburbs, and it
just doesn't work for noir.
Because then if you stand on a
corner looking mysterious in
the suburbs, the police
come over and go,
what are you doing?
So I invented a city
called San Judas.
I basically took San Jose kind
of a million strong and kind
of dragged it up to the Redwood
City Palo Alto area,
which is what I'm most
familiar with.
Anyway so Bobby in this--
I think the other character
that shows up in this is
Clarence, who is a young
journeyman angel.
And Clarence has lots of
questions, because he's just
learning how to do this stuff.
OK, so Bobby has just finished
arguing on behalf of a
recently deceased soul,
and that's what's
going on at the moment.
And Clarence is accompanying
him because
Clarence is a new angel.
"But he wasn't a bad guy,"
Clarence told me afterward as
we grabbed a burger at
a roadside diner.
"Why did you agree
to purgatory?"
"Because even though it was only
a property crime, it was
a breach of trust and those
can go pretty severely.
You don't know Ramiel the way
I do." Ramiel was the judge
who'd been assigned
to Crosley's case.
For a being made entirely of
holy light, he kind of had a
stick up his ass.
"Trust me, our boy will do
that time in purgatory
standing on his head."
"But these are people's lives,"
Clarence said, so
concerned to make his point he
didn't notice the tomato and
onions sliding out the back of
his burger into his lap.
"No, they're whole eternities in
our hands." He looked down
and frowned, then began trying
to wipe the mess away with a
pitifully inadequate napkin.
"Exactly," I said. "They're
in our hands.
In fact, that's kind of
the job description.
So it's better to lose small
than take a risk of losing
big." I did my best to explain
to him that I'd tried it his
way first, going after each
case like a high school
football coach trying
to lead his underdog
team to a big win.
But I could tell by the way he
looked at me that it just
wasn't getting through.
He couldn't see it.
Which meant that if Clarence was
really what they claimed
he was-- a new advocate in
training-- he'd have to learn
the hard way like the
rest of us had.
See, heaven's judges have their
own ideas, and don't
like being lectured on how
morality should work.
In fact, they pretty much
consider themselves to be the
literal definition of morality,
and they have the
power to back that up.
A series of agonizing failures
taught me the most important
lesson of all, which is do what
you can, take what you
can get, try to grow scar
tissue over the
parts that get hurt.
If you can't get the judge to
see it your way, you must take
any little victory
you can get.
I mean, nobody likes to settle
for purgatory, but it beats
the hell out of betting on
a long shot and losing.
Because these are people
we're gambling on.
Human souls.
It hurts bad when I lose a case,
but it hurts them much
worse than it does me.
"Hey, Clarence," I asked as I
pulled my jacket on. "You want
a ride home?"
"I wish you'd stop calling
me that," he said.
"I've seen "It's A Wonderful
Life," you know.
I mean, I get it."
"And when you earn your wings,
we'll stop calling you
Clarence and start calling you
Harold or Harry or whatever
your name's supposed to be."
"Harrison," he said,
sulking a little.
"Harrison Eli.
Yeah, I guess I'd
like a ride."
It turned out that poor Clarence
actually rode the bus
to work when Sam didn't
pick him up.
An angel on one of those smog
belching city buses.
Can you imagine?
I swear I'd walk first.
And then skipping just ahead a
little bit, and now Bobby is
returning to his apartment.
The moment I walked through the
door of my motel room, I
could feel the baking heat, as
if I had left the thermostat
set at 125 when I went out.
Then the smell hit me, so savage
and so wrong that I
took a couple of stumbling steps
backward through the
doorway, waving my hand
in front of my face.
And that was what saved me.
The thing waiting in the room
smashed into the half open
door, and the impact tore the
top hinge out of the wall so
that the door sagged crookedly
in its frame.
An instant later, my visitor
stepped on the broken door and
crushed it into a splintering
mess as it forced its way out
onto the concrete walkway like
an octopus flowing out of a
tiny crevice in the rocks.
But this was no octopus or
anything else I'd ever seen.
It was vaguely man shaped,
but huge--
almost eight feet tall-- and
so dark that even by the
parking lot lights, I could
barely make it out except for
spreading horns on its head
and a sloping, complicated
muzzle that made it look a bit
like some abstract sculpture
of a minotaur.
Even from a few feet away,
the heat it threw off was
painfully intense.
There was no question of
trying to stand up to
something like this.
I turned and sprinted across
the motel parking lot.
I could hear it galloping right
behind me, shedding bits
of splintered door as it came,
so I dove under somebody's
sports wagon and desperately
tried to claw my gun out of my
waistband holster, which is no
easy trick while you're lying
on your belly crammed
under a greasy SUV.
The thing still wasn't making
a noise except for its deep
grunting breaths.
That's good, I thought.
If it's breathing, maybe
it can be hurt.
But it knew exactly where
I was, and it was very
interested.
It circled the wagon, then a
big, hot hand suddenly swept
underneath and missed my head
by only a few inches.
I swear I felt my eyebrows
crisping, as if someone had
tried to close a waffle
iron on my face.
An instant later, the thing
simply bent down and heaved
the whole car up in the air,
lifting it so that only two
wheels still touched
the ground.
I didn't want to find out what
would happen if it dropped it
again with me underneath, so I
rolled to one side and finally
was able to pull my revolver.
I emptied it into the middle of
the thing, all five slugs.
I can't believe I missed from
that close, but as far as I
could tell, it did nothing but
stagger the creature a bit and
startle it into dropping the
wagon, which bounced on its
big tires as I took the
opportunity to scramble
farther away.
We were making a lot of noise.
As the echoes of my shots died,
lights were coming on
all over the building.
I had no idea what was after
me, but I didn't want any
ordinary people getting
mixed up in this.
From what I'd seen, my assailant
would go through
them like they were
made of butter.
My decision was hastened by a
huge, horned shadow scrambling
over the wagon toward me.
Later on, the police who
investigated the scene would
decide that the car had been
vandalized with a blowtorch
and a pickaxe, but
I was there.
Those marks were made by fingers
and toes, or hooves,
or whatever it ran around on.
The screech of punctured metal
was enough to tell me what
would happen if it ever grabbed
me, so I jumped up and
sprinted across the parking lot
and out into the lights of
the busy Camino Real, fumbling
for my speed loader as I
dodged startled, honking
motorists.
This.
This is why I hate carrying
a gun, by the way.
As soon as I've got it, I
suddenly keep needing it.
Most witness reports afterward
describe something like a
gigantic black bear in a
Halloween wig chasing a man
through traffic, and at one
point leaping over an entire
cab, which had fishtailed to
a stop behind a clutch of
startled drivers.
A lone dissenter insisted that
not only had the man also
jumped over the cab--
he was being chased not by a
bear, but, quote, "by a giant
gorilla in some kind of
Viking hat," unquote.
Other than that guy, nobody but
me seemed to have noticed
the impressive sweep of horns.
I reached the other side of the
Camino Real about a second
and a half in front of the
burning black shape.
I was almost weeping with anger
at my own stupidity in
having stayed in the same place
two nights in a row, and
I was gasping for air as well.
But I didn't dare stop.
I was pretty certain my aim
hadn't been the problem with
my shoot the fucking thing idea,
and I didn't have a new
idea yet, so I kept running
until I reached the used car
lot across the street.
Instead of diving under
another vehicle--
I didn't trust the clearance on
any of the economy models
sitting there--
I ran right toward the showroom
window, feeling the
thing closing on me from behind
as if it were a rolling
ball of lightning.
A set of talons as wide across
as a garden rake
wooshed over my head.
As I felt my hair sizzle, I
reflected that at least I had
a pretty good idea now what
had marked my door.
At the last moment, I juked
sideways, and by some miracle
kept my feet.
But the monstrous whatever it
was had too much mass to turn
that quickly, and crashed full
on into the 10 by 30 plate
glass window with a noise
like a bomb going off in
[INAUDIBLE]
Cathedral.
By the time the thing dug its
way out of the wreckage, I was
crouching on the bumper of the
number 35 bus on the other
side of the Camino Real,
heading south.
I could dimly see the shadow
snorting and sniffing in the
ruins of the showroom, but
apparently, it didn't see me
clinging to the bus's rear
quarter panel, struggling for
breath while I bled gently down
the Cal Trans logo and
onto the asphalt that was
sliding away beneath me.
It doesn't really count as
riding the bus, because I
didn't buy a ticket.
[APPLAUSE]
TAD WILLIAMS: Now, I'm very
happy to talk about anything,
whether about the stuff I'm
writing now, other things I've
written, writing in general,
science fiction, fantasy,
anything anybody wants.
So anybody have a question?
Any kind whatsoever?
AUDIENCE: One question.
How do you keep the personality
of characters
individual?
Because at some points, it
must be hard [INAUDIBLE]
always reflect your own
personality or blend together?
TAD WILLIAMS: I think it is.
The question is, how do you keep
characters separate and
individual?
And the thing is, in most cases,
that is more of an
issue in the "Bobby Dollar"
books, more, probably, than
any character I've written,
he is very similar to me.
He's not exactly me by any
means, but his approach, his
way of looking at the world, his
habit of using humor as a
way to cope with things,
is very much mine.
As far as in general, when
characters are not me or not
like me, what really has to
happen is you have to give the
character their credibility.
Once you create somebody--
once you have the basic
integuments of that character,
you have to treat them as
though they are real people.
So what that means is once you
form the basics of their
character, you have to let them
begin to make their own
choices, or at least tell you
what they would be likely to
do in that situation.
Which can be a real pain in the
ass, believe me, because
there are times when you invent
a character solely for
some purpose far off in the
story-- like, especially in
some climactic moment where
they're going to jump in front
of the main character and take
a spear or something and save
your main character.
And so you can't just
invent them at the
last moment, right?
I mean, that's the Star
Trek red shirt thing.
Everybody knows that.
You have to put them in
the story earlier.
And if they have no personality,
than everybody's
going to either spot them as
a born to die character, or
they're just not going to care,
because they're clearly
a spear carrier there--
a walk on.
So you also have to start
early and give them a
personality and let them
begin to develop.
Which is all cool, except the
problem is then sometimes you
get to that point near the end
of the story and the character
essentially will talk to you
and say, I ain't jumping in
front of nobody.
Just not going to happen here.
Which is why I have lots of
other characters, because you
jerk some other poor idiot
out of the back row and
go, you're a star!
Boom.
And put them in there
to take the spear.
But no, it does happen.
But it's vital.
You have to take that chance
that a character will not do
what you want to keep the
characters idiosyncratic, to
keep them real, to let the
little weird little things you
thought of in the beginning
really take shape and inform
that character.
But the nice thing is once you
do start writing them, once
you give them these basic
elements, they do start to
become real to you.
They become real in such a way
that you can kind of let them
make their choices or show you
what they do or suggest what
their own backstory is.
And I have oftentimes literally
found out who the
character was by sort of doing
a psychological overview of
who they are, and that's told
me, OK, they must have come
from this kind of a history and
had this kind of a outlook
on the world because of
things that happened
when they were young.
And so there's a real value
to it, and to letting
them have their way.
AUDIENCE: So when you write
a story with multiple main
characters, do you tend to--
mostly from the perspective of
one, and then you revise it by
saying, does that make
sense from the
perspective of the other?
Or you're a third party that
looks at both of them as
you're writing?
TAD WILLIAMS: Do I see it mostly
through the perspective
of the main character?
No.
What actually happens--
and if you look at the kind of
stuff I do, especially the big
books, that what usually will
happen is that I will
deliberately create focal point
characters so that I can
be in lots of different
theaters of operation.
When I'm doing one of my big
epics, what I like to do is to
show the size of things by
personalizing them, because I
discovered early on that unlike,
say, Tolkien or some
other writers, I don't
particularly feel comfortable
in the all seeing narrator voice
and standing back and
describing to the reader
from a godly point
of view what's happening.
That has never been as
interesting for me, for one,
because I probably just don't
know enough to do that.
So what I've always done instead
is try to find a
character to tell it through.
So then all those different
locales or viewpoints or
plotlines become very
personalized, and they take on
the lens of the character
who's viewing them.
So for me, it's very easy to
step into that character,
then, and continue that
story, because they
have their own story.
They have their own arc.
And it's just like writing many,
many books and weaving
them together, I guess,
for lack of a better
way to phrase it.
AUDIENCE: So when you're writing
a multipart series, as
you are now, how much do you
know now about what's going to
be happening towards
the end of it?
How much is it planned out in
advance versus how much are
you making up as you go along?
And how do you keep it so that
each book has its own
personality, and it's not just
like an episode of a comic
book series?
It isn't just one small piece
that feels kind of
unfulfilling all by itself?
TAD WILLIAMS: Well,
that, actually--
that's a very big question.
It's kind of a set of
nesting questions.
And they are in fact kind of at
the heart of writing big,
epic stories of any kind.
And the answer to the first
part, which is about plotting
everything ahead of time versus
not plotting everything
ahead of time is that it really
is a highwire act.
It's a balancing act.
You think of the guys or gals,
in some cases, that are
walking on highwires with those
big weighted poles.
And as soon as they start to
go one way, then they're
compensating to bring themselves
back to an upright
gyroscopic position,
or whatever.
And that's very much what I'm
doing also with writing a
really big book, and the reason
is because you cannot
plan everything.
If you're writing something
that's going to take you four
or five years, it's going to be
half a million words in one
volume alone, maybe, you cannot
think all of that up
ahead of time.
You can, but it will be
extremely forced.
My outlines have been getting
shorter and shorter throughout
my career, because I realized
that that's a real waste of
time trying to figure everything
out ahead of time
just to tell my publishers
so they'll give me money.
So now I just tell them, just
give me money and trust me.
That works much better for me.
I'm not sure about the
publisher so much.
But the reason is that first of
all, during the course of
writing a very long
story or a set of
connected stories, I change.
I find out more things
about the world.
I bump into interesting
conversations.
I meet people who serve as
inspiration for characters
whatever it may be.
But also just the simple fact
of the emergent order that
comes out of complexity
and chaos--
or at least seeming chaos--
is that to an extent, the
story writes itself.
It goes back to the issue we
were talking about with
characters is that you get
enough variables going on, and
at a certain point, some of
them, you're going, oh my god,
wait a minute.
These guys and these guys are
going to come together, and
these guys have that goal, but
these guys have that goal.
So right away, there's going
to be tension in this
particular thing.
Who are the personalities
involved?
How is that going to affect
whether this group is going to
stay together, split, if they're
going to do this, if
they're going to do that,
they're going
to kill each other.
You know?
So part of it is needing to have
that space for that kind
of order to arise out of a
sufficient amount of chaos.
So you want to keep a lot of
things at bay as long as you
can until they start
to click together.
Unfortunately, the flip side of
that, or the other extreme,
is if you don't plan at all,
then you're going to have real
trouble with things like, say,
foreshadowing, because,
although I write multiple volume
stories, that for me,
they're all single stories.
They're not series books.
So I'm writing them with the
idea that basically you could
sit down at the beginning and
read it all through as though
it was one book.
But publishing and printing
technology of the previous
century did not allow that.
So I began making multi-volume
books.
However, because they are, for
me, one story, I want to be
able to foreshadow like I would
in a normal book, or
begin to introduce themes or
symbols early on the stories.
Which means you have to know
something about the ending,
and you have to know some of the
highlights of things that
are going to happen along the
way, otherwise you're going to
make terrible, terrible,
terrible mistakes where you
will get to the ending and find
out, like, oh my god.
I should never have killed
that guy off.
I'm in serious trouble now.
And short of going door to door
with a red pen, borrowing
your books back-- can I have
that for a second?
See where this guy
says he dies?
He's dead?
No, I'm going to cross
out dead and put
breathing very shallowly.
That's not really practical,
especially not if you're going
to sell enough books to
make a living off of.
So what I have to do is, again,
we go back to the
balancing act, where I have to
make some decisions early with
an idea of, OK, this is going to
come back later on in some
shape or form, even if I
don't know exactly how.
I'm going to establish
it as a point.
The readers will note.
They will say, ah, clearly
a significant moment.
He must have plans
for this guy.
Well, I do, but I have no
idea what they are.
But that's OK, because if I do
this all carefully, one of the
things that happens when things
start to lock up is my
subconscious often will go,
oh, now we're going to get
this guy and deal with that.
Remember, we set that up and
we had no idea what we were
doing back there?
Now we know.
And click, it will come in.
And hopefully, I get to
the final volume and
everybody goes, wow.
How did he know, man?
He just fitted all that
stuff back together.
And it's mostly smoke
and mirrors.
So that answers the
first part.
Was there anything else
there in that
question that I didn't?
AUDIENCE: My second part of the
question was about making
sure that each volume of a
multi-part series has its own
personality and it doesn't
just feel like a small
fraction of a whole story.
But you went on to say, well,
it is a small fraction of a
whole story.
TAD WILLIAMS: Well,
but also, no.
But that's actually a good
point, too, because you have
to put them together in such a
way that somebody can pick up
a book and feel like they've
read a book instead of just
the middle section of something
with no resolve or
no resolutions of any kind.
So I do shape them a bit to
give them that feeling.
The thing about that, though,
is I oftentimes don't really
know what separates that book
out from the previous book
until I'm well into it, and
that's when theme material
begins to rise, I begin to see
my own patterns, I begin to
go, oh, OK, this book
is more of the
travelogue of the country.
This is the book about moving
through this and learning what
there is, or whatever it
might be that turns
out to be the theme.
So those often come
to me later.
But I do try to shape each one
so at least the reader doesn't
feel like they've just
been dropped off a
cliff at the end.
That there's some kind of--
AUDIENCE: So asking a little bit
about you mentioned that
you got better at deadlines
throughout your career and so
on, so I'm curious about
how do you work?
So is it Monday to Friday, 8:00
AM to 5:00 PM on your
desk at home every day, or are
you flexible to just write
while you're traveling?
Is that what you prefer?
And also, if you think you could
be a full time author,
or at least write a real book
while working another job,
like a software engineer,
for example.
TAD WILLIAMS: Well, OK.
A couple of different questions
there, so I'll do
the more historical one first.
My first several books were
written while I was working
other jobs.
I wrote my very first book while
working two or three
other jobs, as a
matter of fact.
I was waiting tables, I was
answering phones at an all
night answering service, and I
may still have been throwing
newspapers at that point.
I can't remember.
But the kind of absolutely
pathetic sad-ass jobs where
you couldn't just have one.
I had to have two or three
pathetic jobs all at the same
time just to scrape together
enough money to survive.
So I wrote my first book, which
was the cat book, while
I was doing many, many jobs.
And I wrote the next set of
books while I was primarily
working at Apple, because
I worked at
Apple in the late 1980s.
But it was only half time.
But that was the last normal
job that I had.
Speaking of, as people here who
work at a very, very nice
company with great benefits and
all that kind of stuff,
you'll be amused by what--
because I had great benefits
at Apple, too.
In fact, they were paying
me full time benefits.
I was working 20 hours a week,
and they had me scheduled into
14 hours of meetings.
So they were basically giving me
full time Apple benefits in
the 1980s for 6 hours a week of
actual expected work, which
I still managed to avoid doing.
So yay me.
Anyway, so yeah, I have had that
experience of working.
And the only thing that really
helps with that is that you
just have to look on the writing
as something quite
separate, and you need to
have it be something
positive for you.
It is very difficult to write
after a writing job.
It is very difficult sometimes
to write if you have a really
physically exhausting job.
But if you are going to do it
while you're doing something
else, it has to be a refuge.
It has to be like playing a
sport or doing something you
really love doing.
As far as how I work now, first
of all, when I first
went full time-- which was
about 1990, I think--
and I first became a full time
writer, I was terrified,
because I was really, really
worried that I was going to
wind up watching daytime
television.
It's like, now I have freedom?
Oh my God.
And I've always thought of
myself as being very lazy.
I'm sure I'm just going to be
watching Wheel of Fortune all
day, and horrible shit like
that-- drinking beers and
watching Oprah or whatever.
In fact, no.
The tragic truth is that now
I'm never not working.
So that's one thing.
It's going on all the time, and
I have to suppress it to
do other things-- to
have a normal life.
To remember to get the kids to
clean their rooms or whatever,
I have to go, turn off the
story for a minute.
Go do this.
In terms of how I actually
physically make books, I
really work most days, at least
somewhat, even if I have
a day when I don't write
anything, I will invariably
spend a lot of thinking time.
But on a normal writing day,
which I try to do four to five
days a week, I will
get up and do my
correspondence and things.
I will then purposefully go
away from the computer and
will just think.
And I'll think about what I'm
working on, and I'll think
about maybe some bits that are
up the road, but I will also
very definitely plan the section
that I'm working on.
Because for me, everything
works better
if it's in my head.
So I like to just keep it all
loose and fluid, and it makes
it much easier to try different
possibilities--
to try little different
branching things, and go,
well, if I do this, then
that turns into this.
But then I can't go over here
quite so easily, so let's pull
that one apart.
So it's just basically that.
I'm sure it's very similar to
programming and a lot of other
kinds of creative things.
You do thought experiments.
So I will usually do that until
lunchtime, sometimes
actually lying down.
It took me years to get my
family trained to understand
that, yes, sometimes
Dad is just lazy.
Sometimes Dad is taking a nap.
But oftentimes, Dad was lying
down because that is the most
comfortable position
in which to think.
So I'll do that until lunchtime,
have some lunch,
maybe think a little bit more.
And then I usually sit down and
do all my writing in maybe
three hours of actual writing,
because I'm prepped.
I'm not sitting there
staring at a screen.
I'm going in with an idea of
what I'm going to do, what the
shape of maybe that chapter
is going to be, who the
characters are, what highlights
I want in it, and
I've really thought
it through.
And usually, I've even played
around with it a little bit to
make things happen in the
most dramatic order.
So that's a good thing to do in
your head instead of having
to rewrite is just saying, OK,
well, if this happens first,
then we've shot the wad at the
beginning of the section.
So let's hold that back
a little bit.
Let's build the tension.
So what else could happen?
Well, this could happen,
and that would
further another need.
So that's basically it
for me most days.
And I'm usually done by 4:00
or 5:00 in the afternoon.
But, again, I'm almost
always working.
So after dinner or whatever, I
will oftentimes just go and
think, or make a few notes if
there's something that I want
to hang onto that's concrete,
like I've thought a good name
for a character and I want to
get that down somewhere.
And I lie in bed at
night thinking
about this stuff, too.
So it never really goes away.
It's kind of there seven
days a week.
And I do a lot of driving
because of it, because it's a
good time to think.
There's just enough occupation
for the body that the mind--
my mind, anyway-- can
sort of roam free.
AUDIENCE: Do you see yourself
rewriting less over the years?
Is that something that you used
to do more and you do
less now, or is that still
part of your workflow?
TAD WILLIAMS: Interestingly
enough, that's almost entirely
project dependent.
With the really, really,
really big books-- the
multi-volume series, with, as
I mentioned, with all the
complications of how do
you channel everything
together at the end?
Those books, like 90% of the
work is in the first draft,
because I have to weave
everything carefully, and I've
got all these different
timelines and things which I'm
holding in my head.
And I'm going, OK, this and
then this, and then we'll
weave this in, and
then this bit.
So those are hell to
pull apart if you
get something wrong.
If you have to pull out a
timeline, it's like ivy.
You're going to have to rip out
the entire plant to get
rid of that one part.
So I really, really plan those
out very carefully, and I do
an even more intensive thinking
to writing ratio.
But with something like the
"Bobby Dollar" books that I'm
working on now, because they're
told by the main
character, because I don't have
to worry about the things
that are happening offscreen, as
it were, I can be much more
direct and fix things
in rewrite.
So I just storm through
those, and I write
faster because of that.
But I also do more work in the
rewrite, because I will
actually say, eh, now that I'm
reading this, I think this
section needs to come earlier.
It's kind of a slow down here,
and I need to do it right
after something exciting
has happened.
And I move things around,
because it's only that one
character and his viewpoint.
So it's much easier that way.
So it's project related.
AUDIENCE: You talked a lot about
process, but I'm really
interested in the earlier
stages of it.
I've read most of your books,
and you have some very, very
completely different worlds.
How does that start?
Like, how do you take that spark
of an idea and turn it
into a framework for a
world and a story?
TAD WILLIAMS: Well, as far as
what happens with the idea is
it's actually, it's funny.
And I guess in different ways,
different people--
there are other people who are
this way, too-- but I am
somebody who the ideas are
always popping up.
They are a constant thing.
My mental image of my own brain
is like, remember those
little corn popper toys you used
to push you around when
you were a kid?
That's what it looks like.
There's these little colored
plastic balls going pop, pop,
pop, pop in there.
Ideas are a given, just
because of the fact
that I am who I am.
I was raised the way
I was raised.
I love them, and I've found
a way to make a
living off of them.
But what has to happen, there's
a big long stretch
between having an idea.
And so what tends to happen
is that there's kind of a
mulching process--
a composting process, where
when I have an idea that I
actually notice and go, ooh,
tha'ts interesting, I'll just
kind of throw it in the hopper
and leave it there.
And what happens is there's this
whole process going on in
the subconscious where really
good ideas will stick around,
and they will often begin to
agglomerate with other ideas.
And in fact, sometimes they'll
eat smaller, weaker ideas, and
they'll go, you're not enough
of an idea on your own, so
I'll just swallow you.
But now you're part
of this idea.
And what happens after a certain
length of time is that
some ideas are so involved and
complex and alive is the best
way I can say it-- so sort
of throbbingly alive--
that they want to be written.
They have gone past the
first threshold.
They are not just a little idea
that's sitting around
there like, ooh, that'll
be fun someday.
And they become an actual idea
that is like a story.
That, for me, is the
first threshold.
And at that point, I will
play around with it.
I will analyze is this
a short story?
Is this a film script?
Is this a novel?
If it's a novel, like, do I
even really want to start
thinking about it?
Because I've already
got three of them
ahead of me or whatever.
But again, it's basically a
Hobbesian nightmare in there.
It's nature red in tooth and
claw, and the ideas are
fighting with each other for my
very limited amount of time
to actually work.
And at any given time, there are
two or three novel ideas
in my head that will probably
never get written.
They will just stay in the
background, and if they stay
in the background long enough,
eventually, they will just
kind of slide off.
Because only once a year at
the most do I ever get to
choose what new book I'm going
to do, and usually, I already
know, because either I'm doing
a series or I've been wanting
to write this one for so many
years that the next open slot.
So it's a limited
amount of space.
That's why I like to do shorter
fiction sometimes and
things, just to get some
of those ideas.
And in fact, the "Otherland"
books-- if you've read a lot
of my stuff, the "Otherland"
books had a huge amount of
beloved ideas of mine that I was
worried I was never going
to get to write.
So like, the house world, the
world that's an endless house,
that was something I'd been
wanting to do for a long time
and I folded into "Otherland,"
which was very much a
kitchen sink book.
Which is why I even had a
kitchen in it with a giant
kitchen sink, was kind of to
show you how shameless I am
about this stuff.
So did we get all that?
AUDIENCE: For someone who
doesn't have the time to do
this professionally and occupy
their entire time, like, I
know I've found I get ideas like
that and I let them churn
and mulch for a while, but by
the time I've gotten around to
have the time to sit down
and do something
with it, it's gone.
Are there any tricks to keeping
track of this stuff?
TAD WILLIAMS: You need an
intermediate phase.
You need an intermediate
phase.
Which is that you need a phase
where you concretize those
ideas in some way without it
having to be a full blown
writing process.
So what I would suggest is that,
for instance, that you
have something like the
equivalent of a story file.
And every time you have an idea
like that, you put it
down in whatever
form you have.
And then you go back to those
things as you add new ones,
but you keep looking at them.
In other words, you develop
yourself an
indeterminate phase.
Whereas me, I've already got a
process in place that leads to
them getting finished, you need
to start developing one,
I would say.
So yeah.
But very important--
it has to be regular.
Because to my way of thinking,
neural pathways, muscle
memory, it's all the same.
Do stuff over and over again, it
becomes habit, you begin to
burn those neural routes, it
begins to become reflexive,
you have an automatic thing,
and you start to also see
things through the filter
of now having those
new pathways, too.
So find some way to use it, even
if you're just posting
them on a blog or something.
Just saying, here, I have
these really cool ideas.
Any of you like these?
Should I do one of these?
Anything you can do to make it
more formal and more real.
That make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TAD WILLIAMS: OK, good.
AUDIENCE: I've been reading a
short story collection by
Orson Scott Card, and he talks
about a lot of that same type
of stuff where he's just
trying out stories
to get ideas out.
And it really has been
fascinating, because he puts
that information in, and
to see that process.
And on some of them,
he goes, yeah.
This one I did, and I really
looked at and said, this was
really a bad idea.
No place to go with it.
But my question was, can you
tell any type of specific
story where you have actually
written yourself into a corner
with, like you said, one of
these multi-parts, and then
what did you have to do to try
to get yourself back out of
that situation?
TAD WILLIAMS: Actually, more
than a lot of writers, I
think, I do that on purpose.
No, seriously.
Because like many of
my readers, I am
pretty widely read.
And I am pretty widely read in
all the genre upon which the
stuff that I like impinges.
So I've read a lot of fantasy,
a lot of science fiction, a
lot of crime, a lot
of mystery.
I also read a lot of
other kinds of--
I read a lot of nonfiction, a
lot of history and science.
So I'm always writing for an
audience as much like myself
as I can deal with, because
I'm the only audience I
actually can test things
against, at least in time to
save myself from a tragic
publishing error.
So what I tend to do is when
I am testing the ideas on
myself, I find that quite
frequently, if I put my
character in a very difficult
situation--
and let's face it, when
you're writing--
let me go to the side here
for just a moment.
The whole thing about
genre fiction, okay?
Genre fiction is
not a quality.
There is no such thing
as genre quality.
Genre just means a type.
And in my way of thinking,
what it actually
means is it's a bargain.
It's a bargain between the
writer and reader, the
consumer, or the audience, or
whatever you want to call it.
And that bargain is if I have
told you, or if you believe
that you are getting a certain
kind of genre book or story,
that I will at least fulfill
enough of the genre
conventions that you will
not feel cheated.
Now, hopefully, I will do a lot
more with it than that,
too, and that's the great
thing about genre, and
especially science fiction and
fantasy is if you give the
reader enough of what they're
looking for, you can also be
as experimental or as literary
or as anything as you want to.
So I always shorthand it as
every five pages, something
has to try to eat my
main character.
But it's not literally that.
Sometimes every five pages
something is trying to blow up
my main character, or to slime
my main character.
But the main thing is that I
need to work with those genre
conventions and realize that
the readers are expecting a
certain amount of
these things.
And it's like a thrill ride.
If I don't deliver that part,
nothing else matters.
Because first and foremost,
most of the readers are
expecting--
otherwise, they could
be reading anything.
Why are they reading science
fiction and fantasy?
Now, once you deal with those
genre expectations, then you
are free to do whatever
you want.
But I also figure that most
genre readers have read a ton
of the kind of stuff that I'm
writing, so I am constantly in
a mental struggle
with all of you.
Any of you who are my readers,
you and I are at war.
You may not realize that.
No, seriously.
I'm going to key all your cars
in the parking lot, too,
because I'm bitter about it.
No, but what is going on is that
I figure you guys are all
really smart, too, like me,
about this kind of stuff.
That you've read a lot, that
you think creatively, and
therefore, if I can just off
the top my head set up a
really difficult problem that
can be solved by my main
character, the chances are,
anybody could solve that, and
therefore, nobody is going to
feel that's a sufficiently
difficult problem to hold
their attention.
They're going to come to it, and
they're going to go, oh,
well, crap, he's just
going to do this.
I mean, that's what I'd do.
So one of the ways to do with
that-- there are other ways to
deal with that, and one is just
to spend hours sitting
around thinking about it, trying
to make a problem with
a great, cool solution.
But what I find is a better way
to do it, oftentimes, is
just to write the character into
a situation that I can't
see any way to get
out of, right?
Because then I really, really,
really have to think about it.
I have to say, oh my god,
he's got no nothing.
He doesn't have a camping knife,
he doesn't have a piece
of string, he doesn't have a
rock to tie the string around.
He doesn't have anything.
How is he going to
deal with this?
Or she, or whoever it is.
And then I'm literally thinking
the same way the
reader is, but I have to come
up with a solution, because
I'm going to have to present
that solution, and it's going
to have to feel that way.
So that, for me is really fun.
I put myself in a situation
where I've got to dig my way
out, and that sometimes hypes up
the adrenaline as a writer
enough that it makes me more
close to what the character is
going through, more ready
to try anything.
Nothing is too crazy.
What might work?
So yeah.
That happens all the time.
In the big books, not quite as
much, again, because I have to
fit all these things together
really intricately.
And I try to solve those
problems before I write them
down, because just otherwise--
Every now and then-- and this
has happened once or twice--
I've wound up writing myself
into situations that I
couldn't get back out of again,
and then I've actually
had to say, well, let's try
something different.
I'll put him in a slightly
different situation.
But generally, with the big
books, I try to solve that
ahead of time so I don't have
to rip out 200 pages of book
to remove that.
AUDIENCE: So you may say that
you don't want to do
something like this.
But I'm curious which
of your epics--
"Memory, Sorrow, and Thorn,"
"Otherland," or "Shadowmarch"
would you want to work on and
put into the theater as three,
four, or eight movies.
Whatever it would take to do.
But which would you be most
excited to actually work on?
TAD WILLIAMS: Well, I can tell
you there's actually two
answers to that.
One answer is that right at
the moment, with George
Martin's success with "Game of
Thrones," I'm going to be
forced to blow my own horn
slightly on this.
Actually, George has said
several times that one of the
reasons he wrote the "Game of
Thrones" series was because he
was involved in reading
my "Dragonbone
Chair," those books.
And I'll tell you
a funny story,
actually, in just a second.
And that was one of the things
that said to him, oh, you can
still do interesting things in
this genre, in this format.
And he's always been really
nice about that and
acknowledging that, even now
that he's richer than God.
And here's the quick short
story, and then I'll answer
the question.
The first time I met George in
person was at a Worldcon--
World Science Fiction Con, back
in the '80s, I think.
And of course, George was not
yet famous like he is now, but
he was already a very
good writer.
I had read several
things of his.
He'd had several award winning
short stories.
Great writer.
And those of you who knows what
George looks like, he
looked like that then, except
his beard was maybe a little
less gray and prospectory
looking.
But he was still a big guy, big
old grizzled beard, kind
of hat pulled down.
And so there I was at
some convention.
There, somebody goes,
oh, and blah blah
blah, and that's George.
And I went, oh my
God, that is.
It's George Martin.
So I walked over to him and I
stuck my hand out and said,
"Hey, I'm Tad Williams.
Real pleasure to meet you."
And he goes, "Get the hell out
of here." I went, oh, jeez.
Um, um.
And I thought, maybe
he's joking, right?
And I said, "Um, yeah.
Yeah, anyway, I really
like your work.
I've always thought--"
"No, I'm serious.
Get the hell out of here."
And I'm like, oh my God.
What did I do?
And I went, "Oh, God, um, gee,
Mr. Martin, I'm sorry if I
offended you."
And he goes, "I'm waiting
for the damn next book.
Go home and get writing." So
nightmare scenario suddenly
turns around.
And I would like it forever
endeared him to me, but I'm
still terrified of him.
I mean, I like George
very much.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
same thing to him.
TAD WILLIAMS: No, no, no.
I would now.
But anyway, great guy.
So what was the original
question?
I had it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
TAD WILLIAMS: Right.
OK.
So because of the success of
"Game of Thrones" and all
that, from a commercial point
of view, the "Dragonbone
Chair" books would
be very obvious.
And again, because of the
connection to George and all
that, and because they were
his inspiration, there's
characters in the "Game of
Thrones" that are named after
characters in those books
and stuff like that.
However, purely on the basis of
what I think would be the
most interesting, it would
be the "Otherland" books.
In fact, we had an option with
Warner Brothers on the
"Otherland" books, which
they let it lapse.
What I found that after they'd
got the option was that they
thought they might be able to
boil it down into one movie,
which is kind of like doing
the Bible and skipping
straight from Genesis to
Jesus or something.
You're missing a lot of material
if you try and
shorten it that much.
I'm not otherwise comparing
my work to the Bible.
But I think the "Otherland"
books, in a lot of ways, are
the most interesting and
original thing I've had a
chance to write at length.
And I deliberately wrote them
to be a modern epic fantasy.
I was writing an epic fantasy
a la Tolkien, et cetera.
But I wanted to write something
that was of my era
and nobody else's era, and it
sprang very directly out of my
time at Apple.
I worked in interactive
multimedia.
I saw the early days
of [INAUDIBLE]
and the data glove and Autodesk
and Jet Propulsion
Laboratories, all this
kind of stuff.
I was doing the rounds.
And I remember actually being
very struck by something that
to this day has informed my
interest in interactive media,
which was one of the very first
interactive environments
that could have more than
one person in it.
And it was called Reality Built
for Two, I think, and
this was done in
the late '80s.
And the guy who was doing a
presentation at the conference
said, OK, well once
we made this,
obviously we got in there.
And the first things you do is
start looking for games and
stuff to play.
So we had catch and all that.
And then because the people were
kind of polygonal, but
you could see that they were
people, and then there were a
lot of polygonal shapes
in there.
So the next thought everybody
had was, oh, we could play
hide and go seek, right?
So people would start playing
hide and go seek in this
Reality Built for Two, these
two interactives.
And then what the guy said
next just floored me.
He said, but very quickly,
people discovered that the
absolute best place to hide
was inside the guy you're
playing against's head.
Because who ever thinks
to look in their own
head for the enemy?
Well, I could have told him
differently, but that was that
idea, that your avatar did not
have physical mass, so there
was nothing to prevent the other
character from jumping
into the other player and just
staying inside you while
you're running around looking
everywhere going, where the
hell is he?
He's like, heeheehee,
in your head.
Or maybe that's just my head
where that voice happens.
Heeheehee.
But anyway, that really
struck me as like, oh,
OK, I get it now.
We're talking about a
new paradigm here.
We are not talking about the
same old three dimensional,
four dimensional crap.
This is different.
So ever since the beginning,
I thought, that's a really
interesting thing to use as
a basis for a very modern
approach to fantasy, where
literally, we are what we
think we are.
And that's very science
fictional, but it also, to me,
was something I could make
it into an epic.
Because literally, everybody
could create the characters
that they wanted to be in
this interactive world.
So how perfect for epic
fantasy quests?
So in that sense, I'd love to
see the "Otherland" books done
as like, a miniseries--
a cable miniseries or
something like that.
But I'll be honest with you.
Any of them are good,
because in this day
and age, it's really--
if you've only been in books,
until you hit that next stage
where they have film and
other fodder out there
for people to find--
it's not that you develop
so many fans directly.
It's just that you're talked
about more, and people begin
to know about you.
So I'd love to see any of those
things happen, and I
want to see them finish the
"Otherland" game as well,
which is currently stalled at
the moment, while it's being
changed studios.
AUDIENCE: Going back to all
these different worlds you've
created, and some of these
epics, one of the things that
I've always thought was great
was you'd finish the series
and I still want more.
Do you ever consider going
back to these and
expanding on them?
I mean, there's the tradeoff
between the neverending story
that goes nowhere, but
sometimes, as a reader, I
really want more.
TAD WILLIAMS: If you had asked
me that question 10 years ago,
my answer would have been
very different.
If you'd asked me then,
I would have said,
I don't think so.
In part because, as you may have
gathered from some of the
things I said earlier, I always
feel like I don't have
enough time.
I've got so many ideas
and not enough time.
On the other hand, though,
what has happened to me
recently, as I've gotten to a
point in my life where I am
different enough now from the
person who wrote these--
I have lived in other countries
since then.
I have had kids since then,
which is a life changing
experience.
Some might call it
a life destroying
experience, but not me.
I am a braver man than that.
No, I've loved having kids.
But, I mean, some of these
things, it's been going on 30
years, 25 years since some of
these books are written.
So I now could come to those
without feeling like I was
franchising my own material.
That's always been my thing.
I hate when I feel like a writer
is writing something
because they've got something
that's making them money, and
if they just keep
writing them--
and it's been a problem
for me.
A lot of publishers have said,
Tad, if you would have just
kept doing Osten Ard "Dragonbone
Chair" books, or,
oh, everybody liked
"Tailchaser's Song," just keep
writing cat books.
I mean, I've had that all
through, because I
don't work that way.
I follow the idea.
But I am at a point now where
I am beginning to look at
things and say, yeah, I could
bring a perspective to this.
And for me, the cardinal rule
has always been, I will not
start anything without the story
coming first, including
something based in a world
I've already written.
But that's kept me from a lot of
those, because I never had
any story ideas.
I'm always working
on something new.
Lately--
without going into
any details--
lately, some fairly coherent
story items have begun to find
each other and down a few
cosmos and get a little
friendly in the great cocktail
party that is the back of my
mind, based in one of
the worlds I've
already written about.
But because if I do do this,
it will be as close to
newsworthy as anything that ever
happens in my tiny little
world, I'm not ready
to announce yet.
But I'm definitely thinking
about it very seriously for
the first time in many years.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Thank you so much for
joining us, Tad.
TAD WILLIAMS: Well, thank you
very much for having me, and
very nice to meet you all.
And anybody who wants to get a
book signed or anything, I'm
happy to do that.
That's why I'm here.
MALE SPEAKER: Excellent.
All right.
He'll be around for a
little bit longer.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]